vous ne le saviez peut-être pas mais le
4 octobre est désormais la Journée
mondiale des animaux et oui à cette
occasion nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de Sofiane terfe lui passe des
journées entières adressées ces bergers
allemands pour le cinéma ses compagnons
à quatre pattes élevés près de
Château-la-Vallière sont actuellement à
l'affiche de dogman le dernier film de
Luc Besson alors comment ont-ils vécu
ces jours de tournage en studio la
réponse dans ce reportage de Lucas
Chopin il y allait
pas bouger c'est chien sont de
véritables stars les animaux de Sofiane
crève l'écran dans des films tels que
sœur de Yamina Benguigui ou les séries
Canal+ 66.5 et Paris police 1905 mais la
dernière fierté de ce comportementaliste
canin est actuellement à l'écran 6 de
ses bêtes apparaissent dans dogman le
nouveau thriller signé Luc Besson c'est
extraordinaire quoi c'est quelqu'un qui
était très à l'écoute qui ne me laissait
le temps de préparer mes actions comme
il fallait et c'était super quoi c'était
pas l'acteur qui se faisait mordre
c'était moi qui doublait l'acteur et qui
faisait qui a réalisé les cascades
notamment la cascade qu'on peut voir
dans la bande-annonce la cascade du
pendu quoi parmi les comédiennes le
berger allemand Lily
[Musique]
nous avons profité de sa présence pour
nous aussi nous glisser dans la peau du
personnage de dogman attaque
[Musique]
le bonheur de ces chiens est primordial
pour Sofiane dans son élevage les
animaux sont quasiment en liberté et
voit le dressage comme de lamusement
c'est un travail quotidien ou d'abord
avant d'avoir des actions de cinéma tout
ça il y a une base d'éducation s'il est
chez moi à partir de deux mois on
commence si c'est un chien que j'ai
récupéré du coup on remet les la base
d'éducation on est sur du jeu le chien
ne mord pas l'humain en soi il mord la
combinaison
que l'humain va porter outre pour le
grand écran Sofiane dresse des chiens
policiers militaires ou pompiers il
élève aussi des animaux parfaits pour la
vie en famille